Today's topic brought to you by, uh, our boys overseas in the UK,
the United Kingdom, essentially. Uh, this guy who's from the UK,
said men should go east to go to Eastern Europe to meet women because the women
over there are more attractive.
Listy. Is your blood boiling? Yes. I'm almost so angry. I can't talk actually.
Um, are you just moaning all the time? Well, well,
that's one of those things about, um, one of those criticisms, right?
It's like saying somebody can't take criticism.
Um, it's very difficult to come back from that. Yeah. Um,
so you haven't got an answer for it. That's very good. I haven't got an answer,
um, about being entitled and overweight. You don't well, no,
I think being entitled is blaming your lack of relationship
success on an entire nation of women.
That's very successful in England. Very, very successful.
But I noticed that every time I saw a beautiful woman and went,
went to talk to her, where are you from old Sweden? Oh, Russia. There's no.
Beautiful women in the UK.
There are for sure.
A lot of them are foreign in London and it's just comparatively there,
way more in Russia. So, you know, you walk down Oxford street,
you see a few beautiful women. Many of them are foreign.
You walk down the equivalent street in Moscow. It's like, my God, you know,
is they're.
Everywhere. A woman from the UK is gonna be off listening to this.
Someone that traveled is gonna understand what he's saying. Oh,
that's all I'm saying. We're not all created equal.
And there's definitely more beautiful people in certain areas than others.
And we like, well, beauty, subjective. Yeah. But we,
we stop societal beauty norms.
You know, we do, it is what it is. And, and, and look at the top models.
What are their last names? Always scar Ava,
all of that, the end, you know what I mean? It's like, come on now.
And it's the same thing for men. Same thing for men. Yeah.
But I said I've home girls would be like, man,
when I go to specific spots in the Caribbean, or when I go here,
the men are so much more. Yeah. I I've said this. I've said this about this,
about here.
Like just here.
The racial of beautiful men to beautiful women is one beautiful.
The 31 beautiful woman. Yeah. The ratio is off. Am I off that?
I just called myself. Not that attractive. It's just a fact. Wonderful.
It's amazing. It's just a factor.
You know how wonderful it is to have so many attractive women,
not enough attractive dudes. It makes average dudes like me slide up in like,
Hey man, I could try. I'm not saying I could dunk. Like he can,
but you know what I mean? I can lay it up, baby. I can't dunk. Like he can,
but I got balls. Hey, <laugh>, let's go. I'm just saying it is what it is. Do.
You think there were any other reasons why you weren't particularly successful
with British women when you were.
Successful? Like I said, you're not listening to what he's saying. Yeah.
The're but heard. Yeah. And you try to, so why you, uh, not successful.
I was very successful with other women. It's just that whenever I noticed this,
it was a lot of, so why are you not successful with, so what you're saying?
So what you're saying like that. Yeah. Like that other girl,
Kathy Newman with Jordan. Yeah.
So what you're saying is that you weren't successful because you're an actor.
When.
I went to Russia, I found the whole package. The looks, the character,
everything, your, your mother's English, right? Yes she is.
So does she also qualify as unattractive, stupid, entitled and the rest of it?
Or is she an exception?
No, but she lives out there with me and she agrees your mothers, all English,
women are awful, even though she's English, no shes,
that they're better out there. Right? She says they're lovely or honest people,
clients, and there's beautiful women everywhere. He said, I.
Think you're just peddling, like a really dangerous,
like stereotypical view of beauty.
You have to understand the reason why now, right now,
what I hear is people that are being but heard. But let's say for example,
I went to Russia, not anywhere in Russia. I went, I went to St. Petersburg.
And the reason for that is I in Russia, there's more beautiful women than men.
There's more women than men because of alcoholism,
suicide war. There's much more women than men.
That's, that's like a fact fact. So you have to take that into accountability.
It's not just like,
it's not just the water in the country or just some men magical thing that
happens in Ukraine that makes a woman beautiful. There there's a lot of,
there's a lot of political facts and things and events that happen
that make that happen. Yep. You know what I mean? Yep. Lucy,
nicotine is a company founded by a Caltech scientist, as well as former smokers,
looking for a cleaner, better ni alternative.
Lucy's bringing you guys nicotine gum in a variety of flavors,
everything from POME, granite, cinnamon, and winter green.
I don't even know what winter green is, but I'm gonna try that soon.
Cause I'm in Canada and it's cold up here.
And what's great about east flavor is that they actually taste great.
So while you trying to kick the habit, you don't have to kick your taste. Buds.
Feel me. Here's the thing.
I've date the people before who smoke and no matter what they do,
you could taste on like you ever tasted a girl tasted not tasted. You know,
I mean, kiss a curl if she smokes and you could taste the,
you know, but with this, you can kick the habit.
And if you're not gonna do it for your own health and your own health reasons,
do it for the people around you. Cause I'm telling you if you smoke, okay,
you smoke a lot. We can tell, I promise you. We can tell. And it's nasty.
And thankfully here at a preach,
we're gonna be helping you guys to get 20% off all products that you could buy,
then they're gonna be shipped directly to your door.
So you even have to leave your home warning.
This product contains nicotine derive from tobacco.
Nicotine is an addictive chemical.
So go to Lucy dot C O to get your products using
promo code ABA. That's ABA. Right?
Um, that is just so damaging for women.
And men complain to Victoria's secret. You know,
if you like those kind of women, then that's, that's what you'll find in rush.
If you don't like that kind of women, then of course I, and I make,
make guys have all kinds of different tastes, right? I meet guys that,
that have tastes that don't, you know,
don't coincide with mine at all and that's fine. But for guys that, you know,
like that stereotypical beautiful woman, that's where you will find it.
They profiling people by where they come.
From. Do you, I have concern about that.
I have a concern about the fact that you think all British women are overweight.
Not.
All obviously.
I mean actually more British statistically.
If we're talking about the obesity problem in the UK,
which is a slightly different debate,
but actually more British men are overweight. Well, rich, we have.
He didn't say that at the men are attractive. These people are so butt hurt.
They're trying to find a way to like take apart what he says.
The truth is I think there is an obesity problem in the UK compared to least to
other European countries. It is what it is.
I'm pretty sure it's the fattest country. The, the,
but it is really because of here. It is.
The UK is the most obese country in Western Europe.
The UK is not the second fattest nation in Europe and Brits are dying in three
years. Girl, wrap it up. We're good. Yeah.
Like he's stating facts here. The thing is this.
Whenever something is not fun to hear, there might be some truth to that.
There might be some facts to that.
You have to see why he's saying that there is a reason for that.
There's a social economy. There's social, there's historical facts.
There's all of these things that you have to take in accountability.
Sometimes it's not fun to hear, but it is what it is. Three English.
Women here, uh, presume. Are they all fat entitled? Stupid? I mean, I,
I don't view of what's your view of the women.
You dunno them, but you, but Richard.
Cast your ears. But I over the women that this desk, for example,
I think that that, that would be rude. I'd like to, no,
this is let see you be brutally honest. Well, I don't, I don't wanna,
you follow you follow this. I've I've got respect for the women.
You've got no respect for English women. That's all point. I'm generalized.
You have zero respect for English women. You are respect.
I'll got respect for men when you're actually confronted.
When she confronted by smart, intelligent, beautiful women,
you can't deal with 'em can't you. Of course I can. I'm dealing with everyone.
Let say what you wanna say, their faces.
I wanna tell you that the women are more beautiful in Russia shock, you know?
And they're very nice. They're great. Honest, intelligent.
They tell you that you're an idiot for thinking those things.
Is that what you call nice. Who's they? What Russian women do you speak? Do you.
Speak Russian? Tell you, yeah, you do fluent Russian ish.
So they can't really understand a word you're saying can't they did your wife
even know what, what are you doing.
UC? What is that? Yo you're so, but hurt that.
The lack yo, the, the, oh man,
the mental shortcut that to take you take to bring to
your point and just to insult this man back,
you're not even trying to understand his point, your butt hurt.
And you're trying to reply to your butt hurt this. That's what you know,
you're none of what you guys are doing here is constructive.
Cuz you're not trying to understand his point. You try to insult them back.
He said something that you took a certain weight now you
got but hurt. And now you just responding with your butt,
not with.
Your brain. She speaks perfect English and I speak very good Russian. Right?
Do yeah. Yeah. I'm gone then. Yeah. Gabriel.
My name.
My name is Dick and I wanna marry you. Exactly. Yeah.
Who are the men that you are helping? Who currently these,
these hugely attractive, good question.
Men who have highly intelligent and want to have successful committed
relationships.
How come these incredible men are not finding women here in the.
UK? I'm a dating coach. I've been doing it for 11 years. I've got successful.
Companies turned over 50 million. We've got million website, uh,
visitors a month. These guys are, are listening to me. They want my advice.
And a lot of them are very unsatisfied.
And the guys that have come and visited me in Eastern Europe in Russia, like,
wow, you, this is like a breath of fresh air. As I said, many,
many men are gonna be really happy with English women. That's great.
Can I just say for the men that aren't satisfied, they can listen to me.
They can take my advice and they might end up very, very happy.
That's that's my job. I.
Think,
I think like you are suggesting that there's a cheats way to being confident
and right with yourself. And that cheats way is to just move abroad.
There's a cheat way of being confident in yourself. Is that what you said?
A cheat way of being confident in yourself? Like what? Having boob, implants,
makeup, changing your hair color. True. True. Hey,
there's a cheat way for everything. You know what I mean?
That doesn't make it wrong. It's just make it what it is. Hey man, listen,
if I wanna lay with fat asses, you know what I mean?
There's a couple African coaches, someone to go visit what?
And in order to be like available in a relationship it's you just have to do the
hard work, to feel right with yourself.
And be able, you have to love yourself. And if you do that,
you're gonna find people <laugh> as the girl's wearing makeup anyway,
like there's not a cheek.
Way. You don't just move your other country.
If you healthy, you know, vegan, yoga, you know, Richards,
the you're gonna find more people. Here's the.
All over the world. I think you are right to seek your future in Russia.
Because I think the chances of you ever having sex in country again are zero,
but it's painful. It's respect.
Married. Why.
Would you say that? It was just funny to watch people get butt hurt. It's but,
but her and Ruth banning, I, it doesn't mean that all the women you care ugly.
It doesn't mean that you're necessarily ugly. If you're watching this,
it just means that on average it's gonna be more ugly. Listen,
everybody it's like me saying that if you go to certain places,
there's gonna be more crime. Are you saying that they're all criminal? No,
it's just more crime. Right? When you go to certain countries, better watch out.
Cuz it's different over there in that same token,
people look different in some countries. People are taller. You others.
They're shorter. It's not my fault. That Filipinos, they love basketball,
but they short. It is what it is, man. They love, they love basketball.
I've never, I respected. I've never seen a country. Yeah. My Filipino brothers,
Filipinos, Filipinos PI tell 'em they love. They love, they love PI, love,
love basketball. There you go. You, you take the paw,
you call your cousin and you set up a match. Hey man,
I don't even know basketball. What I'm gonna say is like, yo,
there's something ironic about like one of the shortest countries in the world,
loving basketball. That's funny. But it is what it is. Yeah.
Whole leagues of there.
If you wanna see tall basketball players probably go to America, probably go to
Lavia side country. You know, you go to Lavia,
they play basketball and they tall. So it is what it is. But anyways, I dunno,
it was just funny watching them get butt hurt. Uh, I had a good laugh,
but if you're from the UK tells what you guys think.
Is he lying or most of the beautiful women in London foreign. Hm.
Do you think that there are more beautiful women than other countries? Hm.
We want to hear your thoughts. Good, good.